well leave it up to Netflix to make a
show about answering the phone
interesting
[Music]
it hurts everywhere Netflix is the night
agent is a 10 part political thriller
based off the book by Matthew Quirk and
in this video we'll be taking a look at
all its twists and turns and deep diving
into its ending so make sure to like And
subscribe because here we go the night
agent follows Peter Sutherland Jr an FBI
agent who successfully foiled a bombing
plot making him both a hero and suspect
conspiracy groups such as the room tone
believe Peter was somehow involved in
the plot especially considering his
father Peter Sutherland senior was
arrested for being a spy so to keep a
low profile Peter has agreed to take a
job receiving calls for a secret program
called night agent in a windowless room
beneath the White House he keeps watch
over a one-way telephone that connects
the FBI with its agents around the world
think of Peter as a glorified 9-1-1
operator little does he know that he's
about to receive a call that will change
his life forever meet Rose Larkin in the
night agent's second main character
who's just seen her multi-million dollar
cyber security firm collapse after a
nefarious data breach she's gone to live
with her aunt and uncle Emma and Henry
who unbeknownst to her are retired night
agents who had been secretly tasked by
President Michelle Travers to look into
that Metro bombing Peter was involved
with they've uncovered that someone high
ranking within the White House was
responsible for the attack but before
they can inform the president two Hitmen
are ordered to take them out whoever
wants them dead knows they're hot on
their tracks and wants to tie up Loose
Ends it's here that Henry tells Rose to
escape and gives her the number and code
for the night agent setting into motion
a chain of events that will shake the
very foundation of the presidency and
Beyond The Season's final episode begins
with a flashback of young Peter playing
basketball with his father when they're
interrupted by the FBI his father is
arrested for treason and will later die
before his name can be exonerated in
court this is the main driving force for
Peter's character he values the truth
Above All Else and wants to prove that
the allegations against his father were
false the truth is everything to me this
is part of the reason he takes the job
working for the night agent program
those who do their time here get their
pick of jobs after they're done but as
we'll find out from the President's
chief of staff Diane Farr later on
there's a far more nefarious reason he
was chosen for this role in episode 9 we
learned that Diane was coerced into the
plot to cover up the Metro bombing by
two men the vice president Ashley
Redfield and a military defense
contractor by the name of Gordon Wick
but you might be asking yourself why
would the President's chief of staff
agree to cover up this plot for 23 years
she's been by President Michelle
travers's side the two are good friends
and she believes in her soul that the
president is making the world a better
place if the VP were to suddenly be
accused of such a plot it would be the
biggest Scandal to ever Rock the White
House and would destroy their chances of
re-election so out of loyalty to the
president she reluctantly agrees
shielding the president from even
knowing about the cover-up to begin with
that's why Diane admits that if the
president had never called a night agent
investigation into the bombing all of
these events would have never happened
in the first place Diane also chose
Peter for the night agent job because he
could make for a good Fall Guy if
something were to go wrong it'd be easy
to blame the guy already accused by
conspiracy theorists as involved in the
bombing itself but back to the VP and
this contractor guy why would they want
to kill innocent Americans this all
boils down to who the real Target is in
episode 3 Peter and Rose find out that
the bomb was supposed to go off
underneath a Giant gas pipeline blowing
up several blocks of buildings but
because Peter stopped it in time the
plan was thwarted in one of these
buildings was Omar zadar leader of the
people's Independence front a suspected
Terror organization based in the Balkans
if siddhar were to take control of the
region he could have access to over 50
Warheads that could put American lives
in danger now the VP can't just outright
assassinate this guy on American soil so
he has to make it look like his death
was an accident hence the collateral
damage of innocent lives to take him out
the VP thinks this is a necessary evil
in order to stop a more dangerous threat
Gordon wick on the other hand has purely
Financial motivations at stake his
company turn like Industries has
billions of dollars worth of military
contracts with the current leader of the
region and if sadar gains power he can
say bye bye to that so Gordon becomes
this sort of muscle of the group who
hires two Hitmen Ellen and Dale to take
care of loose ends including Peter and
Rose who started to piece together this
plot so by the time we get to the final
episode a second plot has been devised
to take out zadar once and for all but
this time it includes taking out the
president herself now this second plot
is all done in secret to Diane who would
never let them get away with killing the
president so she's iced out of this new
plan a plan which in involves bombing
the president and zadar at Camp David So
Peter and Rose team up with Diane to
stop this plot which becomes a Race
Against Time meanwhile the vp's daughter
Maddie is brought along with her father
she's been on her own crazy Journey this
season from being kidnapped shot in the
leg and finding out her dad's been
involved with the deaths of American
civilians she overheard her father
talking about how he'll issue pardons
which is a power only granted to the
president this is how she finds out that
her father plans to kill the president
thereby becoming the president himself
he'll bring his daughter down to an
underground bunker to stay safe from the
blast but as we'll find out later she
doesn't want to be there Maddie despises
her father as a child he blamed her for
the death of her younger sister who
drowned in their pool and for years gas
let her win in reality it was his fault
for not keeping an eye on her now he's
become this overprotective father
because he's lost almost everything in
his life including his wife perhaps this
ties into a psychology of why he agrees
to this plot it's better to be
overprotective in order to avoid greater
pain in the future working for the VP is
this guy named Nathan Briggs he's in
charge of making sure the bombing is
successful which results in him shooting
the head of Secret Service Ben almora
and even Diane Farr herself the question
then becomes where is this bomb Chelsea
Arrington the secret service agent
assigned to Maddie knows that it's
probably in this case she's never seen
these agents before therefore they must
be one of the vp's men luckily she's
able to track down the bomb among a
collection of Photography cases while
simultaneously clearing out the building
and saving Maddie the resulting
explosion causes a panic with the
president and zadar evacuated to the
nearby presidential Chopper but the VPN
WIC have planned a contingency buried
within the chopper is a second bomb but
luckily Peter is there to save the day
avoiding the Secret Service and taking
the president hostage it's important to
note that for half the season Peter's
been a wanted man in connection with The
Disappearance of Maddie it was Diane's
way of keeping him from discovering the
cover-up so all these agents believe
Peter's a crazy man involved in the
bombing and he's lucky to even make it
out of here alive he tells them to check
the chopper for the second bomb and
after a tense-filled moment it explodes
Peter has successfully saved the
president and Vindicated himself Rose is
reunited with Peter the two have
developed a romantic relationship over
the course of the Season Peter mentioned
to her that after the Metro bombing he
became guarded and lost his girlfriend
Zoe Rose has helped him tear down those
walls and as we see at the end the two
are still together speaking of Rose she
has a little one-on-one with an injured
Diane Farr the woman complicit in the
murder of her aunt and uncle Rose could
kill her here but instead thinks the
greater punishment is for her to clear
Peter's name stand trial for her crimes
and spend the rest of her life knowing
that school kids across the country will
learn what a traitor she is Peter and
Rose are thanked by the president
instead of a celebratory ceremony with
cameras and press Peter wants to keep it
low-key so the president asks what she
can do for him Peter wants his father's
name Vindicated but is disappointed when
he's shown a confidential videotape of
his father admitting to his crimes this
was not the news Peter wanted to hear
but maybe it can at least give him peace
so he can move on with his life there is
however a catch something the President
says can never leave this room this tape
was all a setup to make Peter senior a
double agent but before he could be
deployed he was assassinated by a
foreign agent for years Peter thought
his father died in a car accident but
now he gets the truth his father was the
greatest of all Patriots willing to put
his own name through the mud to be
thought a traitor to better serve his
country Chelsea's heroism also gets her
dream promotion to become a secret
service agent to the president she'll
later meet with Maddie who for years had
her life controlled by her father
starting to take control of her own life
she wants to travel abroad and learn to
take care of herself other than the VP
being put on trial there's not quite a
lot we know about his fate but it's
fairly certain he'll be going away for
life for what he did then there's the
question of Gordon Wick that military
contractor the President says he's M.I.A
which might tie into Peter's new job at
the end of the season Peter is offered
an actual night agent role he sent off
to his first gig somewhere overseas and
I'm wondering if it could be in search
of Gordon Wick all we see is this night
action mission brief but there are no
clues here that could tell us what
happens in season 2. Rose also mentions
she'll be back in California starting up
a new cyber security company something
that will undoubtedly come in handy
should Peter need some technical
know-how now there aren't any other
Peter Sutherland novels by Matthew Quirk
so if there was a season 2 involving
these characters it would have to be a
brand new story but what did you think
of the night agent is this one worth
calling your friends about let me know
your thoughts in the comments below
thanks for watching everyone please make
sure to like And subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram at thanksg YT until next
time remember that's impossible this
place is a fortress